nell'ufficio e nel palazzo non mettere
mai non le meta slavoj a 1 con gas la
puglia e chissà se io mi sbottono io non
ho manco le mutande
[Applauso]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti allora puntate di
vita buttata oggi mi farò un tè con pier
luca mariti piuttosto che ciao come stai
bene adesso stava in una posa plastica
così per prendere inquadratura me sbraco
prima inquadratura tutti dicono ma chi è
questo ammazza che bono poi faccio vedè
che invece la scoliosi ce l'ho io non
voglio essere un maleducato ti voglio
subito offrire qualcosa da bere certo vi
dice qualcosa riguardo alla ilte al
ginepro mi piace tanti con noi ecco
ginepro giusto così la cina è proprio ok
né fra e poi ci aggiungo queste cose
[Musica]
ho aggiunto anche un pizzico di fatah
mamma che fisico si vede ragazza in
quanto io fatah lo riconosco una
zolletta certo
grasse non troppo perché poi
cade in arrivo alla tua per luca alla
tua guglielmo benvenuti a vita buttata
[Musica]
la
lega ha riagganciato un anche titani una
volta vale dai ragazzi scusate un
attimo fini ti sentirai infatti comunque
io lo so la notte su di lui sono due
sorelle ma questa dovete censurarlo due
sorelle lo sa che era il film che mio
fratello teneva sotto il cuscino si
chiamava due sorelle le due sorelle era
un porno che lui
sbandierava come se fosse nolan ok
comunque era una storia pazzesca di due
sorelle il cui padre moriva e dovevano
essere le più tonico tra 20 già
complicato come nolan aveva detto essi
non ho capito che c'è un finale pazzesco
queste due dovevano praticamente fare
una una sfida di boe
per ottenere l'eredità del padre alla
fine tutto quanto si scoprirà che il
padre era ancora vivo e le avrà detto
così voi vedete che per i soldi avreste
fatto qualsiasi cosa merde ascoltiamo
l'amicizia possa continuare
[Musica]
io sento le energie di cui
era amico di una by questa qua era una
sua amica sperando che lui alla fine è
ma lui invece la sorella e quindi lei
che ha fatto l'amica e compagnia bella è
diventato un amicizia tossica perché era
gelosa di lui perché la sorella otteneva
diciamo dei favori che le avrebbe voluto
sotto sotto tenere per se stessa ma è
possibile però a quel punto tu mi dici
la chiami amicizia tossica o la chiami
ho fatto andando senza saperlo e la
gente reagisce come reagisce come
definisci di amicizia dossi la mia
amicizia tossica ha scritto al mio
editore di nascosto dicendo che era una
vergogna che venisse pubblicato uno
youtuber andava in giro a dire che lo
che quando ancora non avevo fatto coming
out la mia amicizia tossica si inventava
delle storie
le quali io dovevo pure dare dei
suggerimenti e cose così ma non erano
vere l'amicizia tossica se uscivo con
una persona che mi piacevano sceglievo
lei mette il broncio e sa cosa aveva un
origine non s'è mai capito io il mio
concetto di amicizia mi stai simpatico
mi piace uscire con te condivido con te
anche cose importanti cioè racconto se
c'è un problema sì cerco però la vita è
fatta da 250.000 altre cose che magari
manco mi scelgo e che mi tengono magari
impegnato in casa che lui ti scrivo io
hai fatto purtroppo io ho un consiglio
davanti alle amicizie tossiche bisogna
italiano bravo c'è purtroppo l'amicizia
tossica secondo me lapo gestione
solamente con un allontanamento sono
d'accordo dettagliare cioè tagliare
babbo assumendosi anche le colpe si è
probabilmente quello che altri aspetti
da molti parlano già di te c'è stato sta
già facendo degli il tuo meglio è perché
già il meglio non basta fai del tuo
peggio allontanare o non sono proprio
quello che tutti aspettavo e mi dispiace
perché l'affetto c'è sempre ma a un
certo punto probabilmente
non stiamo stare insieme arriverà un
momento in cui o non incontrerete mai
più o vi incontrerete
no tu hai fatto mai ma qui abbiamo fatto
due delle cappe tesoro in uno non c'era
marco de luca ricorda
verità le 7 e le foto
ecco le foto
mi sono vestito per l'uomo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ci siamo tutti passate nell'ufficio e
nel palazzo non mettere mai
ecco è una giusta sintesi di come
evitarsi problemi perché c'è in ufficio
se la cosa va male in ufficio tu devi
lavorare sei chiamato a lavorare premi
ci si stringe rapporti quello che a noi
lo spieghi ma mi fai in corso asti
incompetenti quasi tutto il tempo ha
cominciato a far cazzi loro no come
c'erano perché la anni sergio e proprio
conto e che tu in ufficio se li e
messaggi col tipo 2 allora fallo des o
nel senso non te pago io finché ti pago
io poi
non emette slavoj a una volta la
spongata spoglia la rifacciamo donne
mathas la puglia non le meta slavoj a 1
con gas ma poi riesce pure la puglia si
e con il coni la poiana e tu parli
spagnolo o pochi passi la nottata
comunità
[Musica]
ho pensato quale gioco potrebbe unirmi
comunque un ragazzo con meier esponente
della moda
a un ragazzo che comunque non ha smesso
di essere
allo stesso tempo unirla quel ragazzo
che non ha smesso di essere quella
ragazza semplice che nei bagni degli
autogrill comunque
ricordo quindi ho detto forse solamente
col tuo aiuto riuscirò a vincere un
gioco questo gioco si chiama fashion o
con noi vedremo delle immagini le rate
diciamo nei momenti nei punti clou e
dovremo capire se è una locandina di una
campagna di moda oppure invece un
pornazzo ok se pronto tantissime persone
vedranno l'acqua e per votare avevano
bisogno dei nostri palette palette
fashion
by e chissà se l'avete capito scrivetelo
qua sotto se non avete capito fateci
sapere in che mondo iritano apre partire
una cosa così è per forza far ciò io ti
dico questa cosa ma mi sbaglierò c'è una
new wave nell'erotismo che ha fatto di
ombre che è fatto di set anche curati
tutti i discorsi ma di fatto altra cosa
hai detto che sono te è porno per me
[Musica]
con cavezzo letto questo che forse
potrebbe essere
ok questo potrebbe essere una pubblicità
di quelle marche che si mettono a roma
nord
giusto tipo abercrombie sì sì sì tanta
oppure
di essere comunque
l'amore è quel tipo di marca che poi
hanno la polo andiamo le fasce
perché tanto
questa qui o e gaz by marciano oppure
no c'è questo qui se non è questo io ti
seguo non l'ho seguito prima adesso se
sotto sotto io sento che se questo sì
dai perchè
cose che era in mezzo ai piedi non
volevo sapere questo mosaico composito
se poi siamo a pompei sicuramente pompei
che semplici mito del broccato questa è
per matrimoni anche tra l'altro no forse
no dopo il matrimonio o pensi che ci
stanno cercando di fregare colpi tipo ci
stanno provando a fregare ci fidiamo il
nostro istinto primi distinto vai
grande era proprio una riunione di
condominio alla pure questa c'è qualche
capo addosso però potrebbe essere
tranquillamente un collo dell'ana sembra
quasi che stia prendendo anche le misure
per far entrare qualcosa insomma lei è
concentrata su qualcosa che abbia grillo
nella cruna dell'ago ora risaliva a
quello è un fashion editing troviamo
proviamo questo io mi fido mai io mi
fido perché un po dopo che mi ha detto
una cosa il trucco io sono entrato in
crisi
inizia tra l'altro sono occupati dei
macchinari intimissimi rende questa
amica mi dispiace ma non ci credo è un
primo piano se questa cosa qua e questo
vuol dire che stiamo veramente se non è
ingrandito qui che cosa vediamo avuta
quale ti sto dicendo
se è proprio una cosa che senso non c'è
niente una mini ruga sembra che stia
facendo un qualcosa di totalmente
innocuo per otto mi ha insegnato una
cosa prima cosa questo trucco due lo
mettereste sulla copertina di moda dieci
anni fa ed è quella cosa che mi fa
pensare a questa mattina
posso dire una cosa qui abbiamo beccato
noi perché io dico e le rughe e
l'espressione perché pensavo che
arrivasse dell'atto è invece arrivata
spetta a noi tu puoi veramente qui
mantenere l'impassibilità totale o
queste fashion secondo me
io sento questo sento pure io no
è amica però nel senso allora un'ascella
l'uomo di ferro adesso che non era una
scelta è entrata tra l'altro tour non è
riconosciuta da più sembrata
io continuo a guardare solamente una
parte che sembra comunque basse talento
dietro l'artista questo e fashion che
c'è un paese con le pareti bianche
europa risale sui 100 per cento certo
era proprio io vorrei tanto fosse porto
però scusa questo quelle sono
letteralmente piume e regoli fascia si è
così difficile questa è la no no no no
no no questo non può essere difficile
per luca ma fa
questo qui a
queste fasce queste fasce andrò per
forza se benissimo ma secondo me qui dai
no non passa fascioli ma diciamo porno
forno
sente giustamente qua io mi dicevo io mi
sento dire poi che se ne porno veramente
si assiste addio ora che pericolosi se
avesse
[Musica]
questa è l'ultima manche abbiamo ora la
spazzola l'aula spargerà star secondo me
la spark costanza bellissimo non è
questa qui la spina se non a spacca
decide la spacca quella roba lì dietro
su cuscini distrae
io stavo gia cerkando delle gonadi
struttura deve vedere di piante è esatto
dire così
però posso dire stava grasso pattern
dietro uno pensa vita buttata no
allora eccolo sei pronto per un audio
come no
strumenti io ho una storia
esclusivamente di sesso da quattro anni
e mezzo di moda con un ragazzo
di cui non conosco il cognome di cui non
so dove vive ogni molto prevede lui mi
sconvolge non c'è nessuno nella mia vita
che mi ha mai fatto sentire così sua
solo che incontra gli faceva fuori da
casa mia fuori dal dialetto non c'è
assolutamente niente
cosa posso fare devo chiudere ciao
michele allora io mi sbottono ma guarda
mai informate mio cioè se non mi
sbottono come posso aspettare come un
ospite si senta a proprio agio io non ho
manco le mutande ottimi perfetto
allora
allora io ho avuto a che fare in passato
con un partner sessuale ti giuro oro
olimpionico dai non sa il nome cioè se
il nome non il suo cognome
non deve essere due niente tesoro i che
era guardami cazzo te frega del cognome
kala che cosa un cognome dopotutto una
rosa deco sarebbe lo stesso profumo
però chi parla è il tuo senso di colpa
ma fregatene ci stai bene questa persona
non sai chi è meglio
mappamondo
non siamo neanche così fanno centristi
vedere però per il panico però io ti
garantisco che in questa situazione
lei semplicemente deve godere del
segmento passo a quattro anni ma grazia
di dio tavoli siani ecco come gli
affitti nel momento in cui c'è voglia di
qualcos'altro nel momento in cui tu dici
tu voglia anche di altro cerca altrove
decidi se libera di decidere vuoi essere
prese in quel modo
[Musica]
io avrei unica grande domanda a chi
magari un po più esperto di me ne vorrei
capire qualcosa in più dei casting
vorrei capire perchè
uomo non l'ha mai di e di dirti in
faccia determinate cose posti gli
assaggi e con spariscono nel nulla per
poi magari di tornare dopo
qualche mese qualche settimana un anno
dio benedica grazie perché sennò non
fidati
la prima volta essere quasi finisco il
ghiaccio col mio ospite sapido suo
intervento arrivano qui e non mi sto
ancora fatto ma le
posso dire cosa 700 militi di acqua
naturale ci hanno fatto bene bravo
perché drenerà dato drenante questa qui
poi è buonissima era bombay è proprio di
danger
[Applauso]
questo qui non messaggio necessario
voglio fargli entrare nel mondo di un
coaster tu hai fatto lo stile
ma perché sembra che stesse parlando che
hai capito la mia nonna vergine ok ok
madonna sicuramente no però allora no
però fisico lucia tu dove sei in questo
casting oltre a stare lì a scrivere
aspettati cima non mi scriviamo non mi
scrivevano mi scrive cara lucia cioè in
ghost ying succede tra due persone uno
non può costare una persona non si fa
accostare cioè per me a un certo punto
alla prima seconda risposta io dedico
questa è una risposta ciao ricco
comunque creato un sacco di problemi a
livello storico ciao ciao ospiti e la
mia domanda è come faccio ascoltarmi un
narcisista che è convinto che torneremo
a letto insieme ma non torneremo mai a
letto insieme io non so più come dirgli
che non c'è trippa per gatti come si fa
mandato via si va dritti blog whatsapp
box facebook blog telefonate ma non
rispondere perché a lei cioè no io
capisco che fate possa piacere
soprattutto le adesso è forte perché
dai no dai no
no no no si sono poi ti piace perché
l'attenzione gente ci piaccia o no chi
c'ha non rispondere più ciao ciao è già
superato di nico d'ascola
arriviamo alla fine di una puntata
strepitose vita buttata per luca grazie
di cuore per sei stato mio ospite
veramente alla tua trash anni manca la
tua ea tutto il cast giustamente perché
voi non lo vedete ma dietro vita buttata
su tutto quanto un ufficiale giudiziario
è stato sociale abbiamo un sacco di
persone a soci prendono pronte ha capito
con le manette
quindi io ti ringrazio veramente se è
stato mio ospite chiudo anche è chiuso
con un non vedo l'ora di vederti in è
stato già visto a teatro ma so che sarai
pubblici per uno spettacolo si diverta
divertente simpatico fresco con una
bella dose di improvvisazione
ho fatto il classico ho fatto il
classico e scortati in giro per l'italia
vi lasciamo qui sotto il link per questo
i biglietti siccome ci vediamo sempre
qui non so quando però sarà un piacere
avervi già dato
[Musica]